tens of thousands of russian troops are
mobilized on the border with ukraine u.s
intelligence officials believe russia is
planning a swift military offensive even
putting in supply lines for medical
units and fuel to support a drawn-out
conflict what we've been seeing in
recent weeks is deeply uh deeply
concerning but the most important thing
is for russia to pull back the forces
that it's masked because
resolving anything diplomatically when a
gun is being held to someone's head
is very very difficult ukrainian
soldiers are ready for war
this military supervisor says he has
fighters who've come to the front line
for the first time u.s president joe
biden says he will tell russia to stand
down when he talks with president
vladimir putin tuesday
russia wants some control over ukraine
once part of the soviet republic but now
an ally of the west russia is demanding
the west stop ukraine from joining nato
u.s military leaders say if russia
invades they will not look away we are
certainly
committed to
helping ukraine defend its sovereign
territory as tensions rise lawmakers and
the biden administration are considering
economic sanctions and bans on russia
from doing business with u.s companies
to pressure putin to leave ukraine alone
it's up to us in the congress to make
clear that we are going to be diplomatic
political and military partners with
ukraine that we are going to provide
them with increased military assistance
so that they can defend themselves
since the start of the conflict with
russia in 2014 the west has helped
ukraine build up its military putin has
denied any intention of launching an
offensive but western leaders want the
russian military to pull back
immediately
jennifer johnson global news washington